- NFT stands for non-fungible tokens.
It's the biggest technology
that has ever happened
in the history of life,
outside of things like fucking fire,
and like the printing press is the one
that I keep going back to,
television, phone, fine.
But this is like printing press 10.0
Contemporary artists
should really be looking at
this technology, I
think it it's a huge win
for the artist financially
and brand reputationally
and for its early buyers.
There was no option them
not to use the high market
art world infrastructure, a
gallery, an auction house.
I believe this gives them options.
What people are talking about, art,
you've covered the people
auction, the $69 million sale
and all that.
But people are misunderstanding
the small contract
and what it can do.
These are smart contract
visualization, right?
Homes and leases, I can't
imagine not every ticket
being in a NFT in a decade.
Once I realized it was this big, big,
I only know one move, all in.
Every person that's
watching this right now
that is lucky enough
to be alive in 15 years
will own multiple things digitally.
People are gonna fixate that
it's just on collectables
and art but it's a platform.
Everyone's gonna say it, that
you're just saving a JPEG.
Just like people fixated that social media
was just for kids.
Social currency, it's why
Mercedes and Nike matter.
It's also how you express yourself.
Everybody I'm looking at right now,
behind the camera is
literally wearing the clothes
they're wearing as a
subconscious way to communicate
to the world.
Everything we do is to
communicate with each other.
As we inherently live more digital,
forget about the metaverse,
ready player one,
we live in the metaverse now.
People are in their screens constantly.
I already know, sitting here in 2021,
that the public wallet
with all your NFTs in it,
will become the next social media.
That when Jason hit my radar,
are we gonna hire this guy?
Just like we looked at his
Wikipedia, if he had one,
LinkedIn if he had one,
Instagram if he had one,
but in 2027, I'm gonna look at his wallet
and I believe what's in his wallet
is a much better indication to who he is,
than what pictures he
decided to PR to the world.
This next six to 12 months,
greed will take over.
Everybody will put out NFTs.
People will buy trade,
sell, steal, rip off,
try to trick you and do the wallet.
There'll be so much
happening, it will collapse.
There is an absolute
guaranteed NFT winter coming.
98% of the projects will go to zero,
but it doesn't mean the
NFT space is going to zero.
It means is that the
craze of the gold rush,
just like internet stock in '99,
will get people to make
bad short term decisions.
That's gonna create a lot
of headlines in 2023, 2024,
that NFTs were fad.
NFTs were shit, but then
just like 2004 and five,
with internet, when
everybody made fun of people
who lost money on internet stocks,
the internet rose like a
Phoenix and ate up our world.
I am completely convinced that's
gonna happen in NFT world.
A lot of you right now saying
you're never gonna own one
and all of you will, so do
with that what you want.
(dramatic music)